[Music]
oh
[Music]
hello and welcome to a new episode of rt
essentials i'm mark ellis and today
we're going to talk about a little
something called science fiction horror
which began centuries ago in literature
this subgenre which often involves
topics like alien invasions mad
scientists and experiments gone awry
started showing up in films as far back
as 1918 and it's delivered some of the
most legendary work ever since
and as we'll learn today some of those
films can be extra scary with one word
titles like alien or cube or mimic or
the invasion of the body snatchers that
last one might have been a few different
words but anyway it's time to take this
science fiction and horror love child of
a genre for a little spin with the best
sci-fi heart thrillers of all time
the fly
[Music]
and creating some buzz on this list is
the 1986 film the fly directed and
co-written by david cronenberg and
produced by mel brooks this movie is
loosely based on george langley's 1957
short story and the ensuing 1958 film of
the same name help me help me jeff
goldblum stars as scientist seth brundle
who decides to test his recently
completed teleportation device on
himself little did he know a house fly
would also make its way into the process
and its cells would start to take over
seth's body as you might imagine his
girlfriend played by gina davis isn't
really cool with these new developments
director cronenberg a canadian filmmaker
credited with helping create what is
known as the body horror or biological
horror subgenre was the first choice for
the job but he was working on what would
become arnold schwarzenegger's total
recall film at the time and didn't get
involved until months later when he was
off that project and he only agreed to
direct if he could rewrite the script
[Music]
cronenberg worked alongside effects man
chris wallace who designed the creatures
in gremlins and was in charge of the
movie's extensive special effects and
those special effects along with
goldblum's performance are two of the
biggest reasons why this certified fresh
film was a hit with critics and fans it
grossed nearly 61 million dollars
against the 9 million dollar budget and
became one of cronenberg's biggest
commercial successes a sequel accurately
titled the fly 2 was released in 1989
and although jeff goldblum didn't return
this new movie was directed by the
previous film's effects man chris
wallace the fly won an academy award for
best makeup but given the academy's
tendency to ignore horror films of the
time many fans of the genre thought jeff
goldblum was robbed of a nomination
and well uh of course he was
the thing 1982
[Music]
here's the thing about the next movie on
this list in that it's actually called
the thing the name of the movie is the
thing got it moving on released in 1982
and directed by john carpenter this film
is based on the 1938 novella who goes
there by john w campbell jr it stars
kurt russell with a supporting cast that
includes wilford brimley keith david and
richard dysart and follows a group of
american research scientists in remote
antarctica who encounter some sort of
well thing that can assume the shape of
its victims development began in the
mid-1970s and ultimately went through a
handful of directors each with their own
take on the story including john landis
until john carpenter signed on to direct
after the success of his 1978 slasher
film halloween the project was put on
hold at one point but finally got off
the ground after the success of ridley
scott's alien which we'll talk about
later and filming began in august of
1981. it lasted 12 weeks mostly taking
place on refrigerated sets in los
angeles plus locations in alaska and
british columbia
[Applause]
1.5 million of the film's 15 million
budget was spent on the special effects
for the creature which was a mix of food
products rubber chemicals and mechanical
parts unfortunately this cleverly
constructed shape-shifting alien was
against a much more family-friendly
alien by the name of e.t and the thing
was released to poor box office numbers
to go with plenty of negative reviews
but it eventually found its audience
through home video and tv areas over the
years and has gained a cult following
that's opened the door for a full-on
franchise that includes haunted house
attractions board games comic book
sequels a video game and a prequel movie
and this now certified fresh film has
ultimately been reassessed as one of the
best sci-fi horror films ever with a
critic's consensus that calls it a tense
sci-fi thriller rife with compelling
tension and some remarkable makeup
effects
annihilation
don't react
next up on this list of the best sci-fi
horror thrillers is the 2018 film
annihilation this one was written and
directed by alex garland a long-time
novelist and screenwriter in his second
directorial effort after 2014's ex
machina annihilation is based on the
2014 novel of the same name by jeff
vandermeer but alex garland had only
read it once and decided to write the
adaptation quote like a dream of the
book natalie portman plays a biologist
and former soldier who joins a dangerous
mission to uncover what happened to her
husband inside area x a sinister and
mysterious phenomenon that's expanding
across the american coastline and it's
as dangerous and mind-bending as it is
beautiful to look at
portman who once said that she would
never do a horror film but eventually
changed her mind for this and black swan
stars alongside jennifer jason lee gina
rodriguez tessa thompson benedict guang
and oscar isaac in other words it's a
who's who of the mcu phase four our
bodies and our minds will be fragmented
into their smallest parts until
not one part remains
annihilation
[Music]
and speaking of oscar isaac he was
filming the last jedi at the same time
as this one on an adjacent studio lot
using his star wars trailer for both
projects and even filming scenes for
both films in the same day after a poor
test screening one studio exec thought
annihilation would be too complicated or
intellectual for audiences and demanded
changes to portman's character and the
ending but neither alex garland or
producer scott rudin who had final cut
agreed with those notes and the changes
were never made many feel this led to a
deal being made with netflix to
distribute the film internationally
shortly after it opened in theaters that
led to just 43 million dollars at the
box office a major flop despite its
certified fresh status with critics and
being a hit with the fans who did see it
the terminator
i'm a friend of sierra connor i was told
that she's here could i see her please
no can't see her she's making a
statement
where is she
look it may take a while i want to wait
there's a bench over there
[Music]
i'll be back
being sent from the future well
technically the past to the next spot on
this list is 1984's the terminator the
film is directed by james cameron who
came up with a premise after a fever
dream he had while making his first film
piranha 2 the spawning this film follows
a cyborg assassin known as a terminator
played by arnold schwarzenegger who
travels from 2029 to 1984 to kill sarah
connor played by linda hamilton her
unborn son poses an eventual threat to
skynet an artificial intelligence system
that's going to be responsible for a
nuclear holocaust filming was delayed
while schwarzenegger finished conan the
destroyer so james cameron worked on
scripts for rambo first blood part 2 and
aliens in the meantime
wash day tomorrow
nothing clean
right
nothing clean right
i think this guy's a couple can short of
a six-pack you're close
give them to me now as for this script
the initial outline involved a second
terminator that was made of liquid metal
but cameron felt the technology of the
time wasn't ready although that would
eventually come to pass in the 1991
sequel terminator 2 judgement day but
the effects they did use for this film
which included stop-motion animation and
miniatures were created by a team led by
the legendary stan winston and the
result is a film that is credited with
launching james cameron's career and
officially cementing arnold
schwarzenegger status as a leading man
although things could have been
different considering sylvester stallone
and mel gibson both reportedly turned
down the terminator role and o.j simpson
was suggested but it was decided that he
wouldn't be believable as a killer
ironically enough the film's success led
to a franchise consisting of several
sequels a television series comic books
novels and video games and it all
started with the terminator's famous
line i'll be back which was actually
originally scripted as i'll come back
the more you know
the invisible man
[Music]
making itself seen next on this list is
the invisible man from 2020 this is a
reboot of the invisible man film
franchise the first of which was
released in 1933 and all adapted from
the novel of the same name by h.g wells
first published in 1897. relative
unknown oliver jackson cohen was cast as
the titular character having just
appeared in the haunting of hill house
miniseries he plays a crazed scientist
who after staging his own suicide uses
his power to become invisible and
terrorize his ex-girlfriend played by
elizabeth moss the filmmakers used a
combination of new age cgi magic and old
school techniques to bring the invisible
man to life while the rest of the film
was brought to life by director lee
juanelle who was born in australia where
this film was shot one l who broke into
hollywood as an actor with films like
saw has also directed the horror flicks
insidious chapter 3 and the sci-fi movie
upgrade so he's qualified in both genres
to combine them here now is what i'm
trying to tell you
get back in bed now
[Music]
before when out came along though
development for this film began way back
in 2007. at the time there were plans of
an expanded dark universe for universal
with johnny depp playing the invisible
man those plants officially fell apart
after the mummy was considered to be a
flop 10 years later in 2017 and the new
plan or pivot if you will was to focus
more on filmmakers bringing their own
unique approach to the characters in
standalone films this also meant
steering away from big budgets which
rarely works in horror anyway and that's
why with a budget of just 7 million for
the invisible man its strong box office
was a huge win
this certified fresh film grossed 142
million dollars worldwide and that's
with the theatrical release it was cut
short by cobit 19 and switched to
streaming just three weeks after it
opened and like our old pal the critics
consensus says this film proves that
sometimes the classic source material
for a fresh reboot can be hiding in
plain sight
cube
well he's right
not prime
stop
in front of you
[Music]
taking shape is the next film on this
list is the 1997 sci-fi thriller cube
this independent canadian film was
co-written and directed by vincenzo
natali who also did the 2009 sci-fi
horror film splice if the premise was a
joke you could say that a scientist a
former cop a math genius a master of
escapes and an architect walk into a
prison of cubic cells and have no idea
how they got there but this is no joke
and that's actually quite terrifying
in fact some of the cubes are booby and
the prisoners have to try and use their
combined skill sets to figure out a way
to escape or they're gonna die this film
has been compared to and was reportedly
inspired by a 1961 episode of the
original twilight zone called five
characters in search of an exit in this
one it's six main characters all named
after a real world prison and through
various iterations of the script the
imprisoned group took on a number of
different forms including all being
accountants or all being criminals i
don't wanna die i'm just being realistic
you think they'd go to all the trouble
to build this thing if we could just
walk out you think they would have left
us clues and let us beat it so far if
there wasn't a way out you think we
matter we don't put us out of your
misery so we can get on with getting out
of here oh you're not getting out of
here yes we are no you're not yes we are
there is no way out of here cube was
filmed on a toronto sound stage over the
course of 20 days with the majority of
it being shot on a handheld camera the
cube in the film was conceived by
mathematician david w pravika who also
served as a math consultant for the
production and only one full-size cube
with 14 foot walls was actually built
for filming and they changed the colors
of each room by using sliding panels
despite a modest nine million dollar
hall with the worldwide box office this
film has gone on to achieve cult status
one of those 90s deep cuts where if you
know you know
you know
it was followed by a sequel cube2
hypercube and a prequel cube0 both
released in the early 2000s there was
also an american remake rumored to be in
the works back in 2015 but nothing has
come of it just yet but fear not all you
cube heads or cubers will cubies
whatever you want to call yourselves
there is a japanese remake released in
2021 so
you know go cube it up
event horizon
miller
captain miller
i've got the problems here
[Music]
next we'll keep it in 1997 but head into
space with the film event horizon this
one was directed by paul w s anderson
best known for the resident evil film
franchise and stars lawrence fishburne
sam neil kathleen quinlan and julie
richardson the movie is about a
spacecraft named the event horizon that
suddenly reappears after having vanished
years earlier and the crew that is set
to investigate what they find is this
seemingly abandoned ship that has some
serious horrors lurking in its corridors
the english director anderson found
success with 1995's more at all combat
and was hounded with new offers to
direct he ultimately turned down the
mortal kombat sequel phew as well as
2000's x-men so he could put his focus
into an r-rated horror flick instead of
a standard pg-13 fair
if what dr wade tells us is true
this ship has been beyond the boundaries
of our universe
of known scientific reality
who knows where it's been
what it's seen
and what it's brought back with it
and looking to avoid being a copycat of
1979's alien anderson rewrote the script
with the idea of a classic haunted house
movie in his head looking to films like
1963's the haunting and stanley
kubrick's the shining for inspiration
unfortunately event horizon had a bit of
a troubled production in part because it
had become clear that some movie called
titanic wasn't going to be ready in time
because of that paramount rushed the
filming and editing of this movie
hastily cutting about 35 minutes of
footage from the original cut in the
process the film was considered a
commercial failure grossing just 42
million dollars on a 60 million dollar
budget but people began to see the light
during its initial dvd release in fact
things were going so well that paramount
called up anderson to see if he could
prep a director's cut dvd with all that
deleted footage only to discover that
most of it was either lost or destroyed
oops
invasion of the body snatchers
see
[Music]
grabbing the next spot on this list of
the best sci-fi horror thrillers is
1978's invasion of the body snatchers
this film was directed by philip kaufman
and is based on the 1955 novel the body
snatchers by jack finney which was
previously adapted into the 1956 film of
the same name featuring stars like
donald sutherland jeff goldblum and
leonard nimoy this movie tells the story
of a san francisco health inspector and
his colleague who discovered that humans
are being replaced by alien duplicates
but devoid of human emotion behind the
scenes sound editor ben burt who is
coming off of star wars the year before
was brought in along with the grateful
dead's jerry garcia to help create the
sounds and banjo music in the movie the
special effects seen in the film were
created live for the camera while the
director kaufman instructed his actors
to fill the time between dialogue with
facial expressions
[Music]
this version of invasion of the body
snatchers comes with a twist ending
something that kaufman kept secret right
up until filming telling sutherland the
night before the scene was shot and
rumor has it that studio execs didn't
find out until later when a screening
was happening at george lucas's house
you gotta love hollywood the movie hit
theaters over christmas weekend in 1978
because nothing says happy holidays like
body snatching and pulled in a decent
hall at the box office with some buried
reviews but critical reception for this
now certified french film has greatly
improved over the years with many
publications calling it one of the
greatest remakes and one of the best
sci-fi horror movies ever and perhaps
the highest honor it can receive was
being parodied in a 2012 episode of
spongebob squarepants enough said
mimic sometimes an insect will evolve to
mimic its predator
a fly can look like a spider
a caterpillar can look like a snake
the judas evolved to mimic its predator
[Music]
us
and because 1997 was apparently the year
for sci-fi horror flicks next on this
list is 1997's mimic this film was
directed and co-written by guillermo del
toro and inspired by a 1942 short story
of the same name by award-winning
science fiction author donald a wolheim
the movie is about an evolutionary
biologist played by mira sorvino who's
trying to stop a cockroach spread plague
that threatens to take out the children
of new york city but in the process her
and her team create a legion of insects
that evolved to mimic and hunt
humans i'm sorry human hunting bugs yeah
that's going to be a big no from me dawg
mimic also features josh brolin who
appeared in another miramax horror film
the same year with nightwatch plus it
marks the feature film debut for norman
reedus who went on to star in the hit
series the walking dead as daryl
um
do you have the time
is through the time
one miramax executive reportedly argue
with guillermo del toro regarding the
film's tone claiming it wasn't scary
enough ultimately del toro was not given
final cut privileges and didn't approve
of the film as released but a director's
cut running six minutes longer than the
original was eventually put out in 2011.
the original version was ultimately a
disappointment at the box office
although it was followed by two
direct-to-video sequels neither of which
involved del toro but as this fresh film
has been looked upon more favorably
throughout the years a tv adaptation was
announced in 2020 with paul w s anderson
directing the pilot no word on the
project lately but hopefully someone
will be mimicking this one soon
alien oh god it's moving towards you
[Music]
move get out of there
[Applause]
[Music]
and finally making contact as the last
film on our list is 1979's alien this
one was directed by ridley scott in just
his second feature film it follows the
crew of a commercial starship who are
awakened from a deep sleep in space to
find that a deadly alien life form has
joined them for a ride this movie marked
the first lead role for sigourney weaver
who came in with broadway experience but
as a relative unknown in film scott said
that the role of ripley came down to
weaver and meryl streep with weaver
ultimately winning the job meanwhile for
the other lead role harrison ford turned
down the part of captain dallas which
eventually went to tom garrett scott
said the concept for ailing was inspired
partly by star wars a couple years
earlier which deviated from the pristine
future often depicted in science fiction
films at the time
[Music]
filming took place over the course of 14
weeks in the summer and fall of 1978
with what was a pretty low budget at the
time of 11 million dollars in fact some
of the laser lights seen in the alien
ship were reportedly borrowed from the
band the who who were testing out lasers
for their show on the sound stage right
next door that's convenient and alien
went on to become a commercial success
and launched a media franchise that
includes novels comic books your video
games your toys and more films like
sequels prequels and even a crossover
with a predator franchise i think paul
ws anderson has a hand in that too plus
the very certified fresh film which won
an oscar for best visual effects has
cemented a legacy as one of the greatest
science fiction horror films of all time
even being selected for preservation in
the united states film registry which is
a mic drop well there you have it the
best sci-fi horror thrillers i know i
know you think this list maybe should
have looked a little different weren't
there 12 monkeys that were involved but
you know it's only 10 movies we get here
and it's a tough decision to make so let
us know the sci-fi heart thrillers that
you love and in the meantime just
remember these words thing fly cube
mimic terminator and body
and snatchers
an invasion thanks for tuning in to rt
essentials i'm mark ellis
and i hope i'll be back
[Applause]
[Music]
you